good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
the archbishop of canterbury justin
welby will lead a remembrance service at
canterbury cathedral this morning
following the death of the duke of
edinburgh prince charles has led the
royal family in thanking the public for
its support saying prince philip
would have been touched by the
outpouring of feeling in recent days
meanwhile buckingham palace has said the
duke's funeral will take place on
saturday at windsor castle
in a service modified to comply with
coronavirus restrictions
our royal correspondent ran on mills
reports
they are a family in mourning grieving
the loss of a husband
father and grandfather stepping in where
the duke would once have been supporting
the monarch
the first official public tribute coming
from his eldest son
i i particularly wanted to say that
my father i suppose the last
uh 70 years has given the most
remarkable devoted service
uh to the queen to my family
and to the country and also to the whole
of the commonwealth
and as you can imagine my family and i
miss my father enormously he was a
much loved and appreciated figure
my dear papa was uh was a very special
person who
i think above all else would have been
amazed by the reaction
and the touching things that have been
said about him
and from that point of view we are my
family deeply grateful
for all that it will sustain us in this
particular loss and at this particularly
sad time
thank you thank you
as crowds gathered outside windsor
castle where prince philip
died on friday morning other members of
the family were visiting the queen
their son prince andrew driving himself
past the well-wishers
in a separate car prince edward and the
council of wessex
drove slowly thanking those who'd come
to pay their respects
sophie with tears in her eyes telling us
her majesty was doing okay
he never wanted the pomp and ceremony
that his national service meant he was
entitled to
in the end the pandemic the reason his
funeral plans have been significantly
scaled back
the funeral will take place at windsor
castle next saturday
at three o'clock there'll be no public
access
or public processions and the event will
be within the current covid guidelines
but still very much reflect the personal
wishes of the duke
there will be a national minute silence
at three o'clock
so even without covid i think we would
have had a scaled down
funeral but clearly now this is going to
be very small it's going to be in line
with covered regulations of below 30
and it will be essentially a ceremonial
it will be a sort of commemoration
of philip's life but not the great
international event that it would
otherwise have been
we are still waiting for the full guest
list but his children
and grandchildren are expected to attend
including the duke of sussex but megan
who's expecting her second child
will not because of doctor's advice
windsor has played host to so many big
royal events over the years
and usually these streets be packed with
tens
of thousands of people the next weekend
all of the events surrounding the
funeral will take place behind the
castle walls
yes there will be a procession and there
will be a large military presence
but we're all being encouraged to watch
it from our own homes
in recent years since he retired the
queen's official duties meant they had
spent time apart
the pandemic bringing them back together
at windsor
the family have always described
themselves as her
supporting cast their comfort never
needed more
as they prepared to give the duke of
edinburgh a fitting
farewell rhiannon mills sky news at
windsor castle
well i'm joined now by the royal editor
of the daily mayor
russell myers good morning to you we
know now that the funeral will be next
saturday but before that
a remembrance service to be held at
canterbury cathedral this morning
good morning julian uh we do and there's
more details of the funeral coming out
yesterday
and uh you know i dare say a bit of
light-heartedness
in the in the doom i think it was a
beautiful tribute
by uh prince charles he was speaking of
how the family were incredibly touched
by all the well-wishers throughout the
not only the country but the world i
think they've been
absolutely uh shocked at the outpouring
of emotion
but also you know small incredible
details like uh
prince philip had designed his own land
rover to
transport his coffin which was part of
the original
plans for his funeral and obviously they
have been scaled back
massively and had to be signed off by
the queen um
very very a short notice but um i think
it'll be small details like that that'll
be in keeping with his wishes he
wouldn't have wanted a fuss
and uh and still as the palace say it
will be in line with his wishes and it
will be a tremendous
send-off yes we know that he didn't want
a big affair and
there won't be any public access or all
processions
the uh palace advising people to to stay
away
no i i think that's right and they were
very very conscious acutely aware i was
told of how
many people really did want to pay their
respects however we are still
in a lockdown situation obviously things
are going to change tomorrow however
they they have people's safety in mind
and they
were it discouraging people from
gathering at the uh royal palaces
buckingham palace
in a hollywood house and windsor castle
and to
instead of leaving flowers at these
locations to perhaps think of
a charity donation that you may wish to
make yourself or indeed
one of the many many charities and
organizations that the duke of edinburgh
had an affiliation with
we're waiting for the full guest list
but we do know that the prime minister
boris johnson
has given up his place so that a member
of the royal family can attend
instead of him yes indeed and um
number 10 said yesterday that uh boris
john was
again very aware that this was a family
and morning
the restrictions on pla in place with
any funeral going ahead at the moment
means only 30
members can attend and certainly the
queen will be going through that list
and as we speak in the coming days to
try and whistle it down
there would have been so many people not
only just in the wider family but
again in the many many associations and
uh
patronages that he held that would have
wanted to pay their respects but it is a
very very different situation and
it will be televised and people are
advised to sort of
remember the duke of edinburgh in their
own way from home in their in their in
the safety of their own home
and one of those uh to be in attendance
almost certainly uh prince harry
returning from america yes confirmed
yesterday i mean it was uh
the last couple of days it's been uh
rumored but confirmed by the palace
yesterday
that the duke of sussex will be
returning
for his grandfather's funeral and no
doubt this will um
be fraught with tension it's it's not uh
too long since the oprah winfrey
interview he hasn't seen
any of his family since around the uh
the
early march last year just days before
the the national lockdown um
megan won't be coming she's of course
heavily pregnant with their second child
we understand
had been advised by her doctors not to
make the journey from from california
but um
one would hope that the family can put
their differences aside no doubt those
issues are still very very raw of the uh
the issues raised in the oprah winfrey
interview accusing the
royal family of uh of racism of
abandonment when
megan was having issues when she was
pregnant with their son archie but
again this is this is a family united in
grief i think
um is what all sides are saying and uh
and one
will wish them that they can put their
differences aside especially for this
occasion
uh we know that according to the queen's
wishes there'll be
two weeks of raw morning starting from
yesterday what exactly will that entail
well engagement still can go ahead i'm
not too sure
there are a couple of engagements in the
diary over the next week um
and there is no confirmation whether
they will go ahead um
there isn't any protocol to say that
they they shouldn't um
you know go ahead and and people will
want to see the family out and about i
think that
in in your package there you saw prince
charles um
speaking so eloquently about his father
uh
countess of wessex as well looking
teary-eyed that she is
no doubt supporting the queen saying
that the queen had been
amazing but um i do think that we'll
perhaps see more statements from the
royal family over the coming days
because they are
very very aware that people want to
remember the duke of edinburgh
and um and really share in their grief
to remember a remarkable man who had a
remarkable
remarkable life and a royal career
russell myers thank you very much for
speaking to us royal editor
at the daily mirror thank you
retailers across england are hoping that
pent-up demand will bring people
flooding back to the shops tomorrow
after a year of closures and
restrictions
but with a number of measures still in
place there's no guarantee that shops
and restaurants will bounce back
our home editor jason farrell has been
to covent garden in the heart of london
to see preparations for reopening
will monday mark the beginning of the
recovery
covent gardens gearing up for when
restaurants can serve outside
and non-essential shops reopen do you
worry that the world has gone online
and it will never get back to what it
was not at all covent garden's been
around for 500 years we're very
confident it'll be around for a very
long time
i think both of those things can
co-exist and every time we've had a
lockdown and we've had an easing of
lockdown
what we've seen is restaurants full
shops full
cues to get in people wanting to come
out connect with each other at a very
very human level
but also experience the best of london
for many the pandemic hit home with
these images
of london emptying out just before the
first lockdown in march 2020.
how could the bustle of 44 million
visitors a year to covent garden
just vanished back then traders at
jubilee market
hoped it would be a brief shutdown
you've been here since 78
but a year on and the market's not ready
to open
because last summer they didn't have the
trade
when we did come back the market was
absolutely desolate the west end was
desolate
yeah but we were especially quiet
because we depend on tourists both
domestic and foreign and obviously there
was no foreign tourists
there's no museums to go to there's no
theaters to go to
it there's no point in you opening your
business until
until there's a reasonable footfall over
the course of 2020
the valuation of the covent garden
estate has plunged
by a quarter the landlord has had to
restructure leases
and waive rent from struggling tenants
and only the hardiest
kept going like the florist who began
trading shrubs
to become a garden center the waldorf
and the savoy then off to opening until
the 17th of may yeah
so if there's nobody staying here and
there's certainly no
theaters i think it's going to take a
lot longer than people realized
to cover especially in uh central
illinois look at the streets here it's
empty the only people walking around
unbelievably are traffic wardens where
there's no cars and there's no
people this is a place where time has
stood still where livelihoods have been
put on hold but now you can just start
to feel it
the buzz is returning london is getting
ready
to put on a show but the question is
who's coming
this place can't thrive can it really
until the airports are open
and the hotels are open and the theaters
are open i think it's a really good
point you do need a lot of things to
work together
i think we have to remember that you
know somewhere like covent garden
it's both for the international tourists
but it's also for the londoner it's for
the domestic audience
it's a slow phased uncertain coming back
to life
on monday the piazza will have 800 seats
heaters and
umbrellas food alcohol and hopefully
lots of people jason farrell sky news
almost seven million people have now
received two coronavirus vaccinations in
the uk the latest covert figures show
2589 new cases were reported in the most
recent 24-hour period
with 40 more deaths across the uk
that takes the total number of people
who've died to 127
000 and 80. the figures also show that
more than
32 million people have now had their
first vaccine
dose
david cameron told a senior number 10
adviser it would be
nuts to exclude a company he was working
for from a coronavirus loan scheme
according to an email published today by
the sunday times
the newspaper also reports the former
prime minister took his boss financier
lex greensell for a private drink
with the health secretary matt hancock
to discuss a payment scheme which was
later rolled out in the nhs
our political correspondent rob pal is
in westminster for us now
but what's the detail behind this very
latest allegations then
so these are more allegations published
by the sunday times which essentially
detail um the extent of lobbying that
former prime minister david cameron is
thought to have engaged
in on behalf of a financial services
firm green sill capital
that he went on to work for after he
left downing street now the sunday times
um has published a lengthy email which
they say david cameron sent to a senior
number 10
advisor last year after the treasury had
already rejected an application
from the firm for access to a covered
loan scheme now i think what's striking
reading this email is really the tone of
it and the amount of pressure that david
cameron
appears to be trying to put on officials
to allow this company um
into the mix on this now the email reads
that it says
it seems nuts to exclude the type of
firm
such as green seal capital from this
scheme and that what we need to do is
find a way for rishi soon act the
chancellor
to have a good look at this and ask
officials to find a way of making it
work
now this of course comes after david
cameron sent text messages to rishi
sunak's
personal phone pressing the case for
this firm to be involved and also
lobbied other
treasury ministers as well now
separately the sunday times also reports
um on a private drink which david
cameron had with matt hancock alongside
lex greensill the person that ran this
financial services company
to discuss a payment scheme that was
later rolled out in the nhs
now we haven't heard anything from david
cameron on any of these
accusations right from the beginning
when they started to
unfold but number 10 has said overnight
that during the pandemic
they were approached by an immense
number of companies to discuss the
response
and the various emails were passed on to
the relevant departments
now clearly this is leading to calls for
more transparency when it comes to
lobbying especially as david cameron was
found to have acted
within the guidelines because he was an
employee of this company
remember it was 2010 that david cameron
said that lobbying
was going to be the next big scandal i
don't think he quite had this in mind
when he said that though
indeed rob thank you
the caribbean island of saint vincent
has been blanketed in a layer of ash
following the spectacular eruption of a
volcano on the island
more than 3 000 people have been put up
in shelters
with around 16 000 told to evacuate
their homes
in 1902 more than a thousand people died
when the volcano erupted
but this time they've been no injuries
or deaths reported sally chowdhury
reports
hard to believe these are daytime
pictures
the air dense with thick ash falling
from the sky
you can still hear the volcanoes rumble
la sofia volcano erupted spectacularly
on friday
pumping clouds of ash six miles into the
air
i can hear the rumblings i don't know if
you guys can hear it
those who live too close were ordered to
evacuate
some took shelter out of school where
prime minister ralph gonzalez
offered comfort we don't know how much
more is going to come out but it is very
good it's coming out
so far we have done well in that
nobody get injured
ash clouds almost completely cover the
tiny island of saint vincent
its population of a hundred thousand
largely tucked away inside
and on the ground just look at these
footprints
not snow but in ash
the disaster response team warned this
could go on until july
or august difficult months ahead for the
farming and
agriculture sectors sardia chowdhury sky
news
time now to take a look at the morning's
other main stories for you now and a 34
year old man has been charged with the
murder of the millionaire hotelier sir
richard sutton
the 83 year old died on wednesday during
an incident at a property near
gillingham in dorset
thomas schreiber from gillingham has
been charged with murder
attempted murder and dangerous driving
and is due before magistrates in poole
tomorrow
a woman in her 60s named in report as
sir richard's wife
remains in a critical condition in
hospital
one of the stars of big brother nikki
graham has died age
38 following a long battle with anorexia
she'd recently checked into a private
hospital to treat her eating disorder
after a fundraising campaign organized
by friends
and fans
and if you've been affected by any
issues mentioned there you can get in
touch with
beat eating disorders 10808 201-1677 the
number on the bottom of the screen for
you
time now for a look at the weather good
job
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning to you well the weather
looks like settling down through the
coming week and temperatures recovering
if not to average for the time of year
perhaps a little above
but right at the moment it's still quite
wintry we've got wintry showers around
north facing coasts
and we'll see a few of those appearing
in land through the course of the day
early warnings still out for snow and
ice running from greater manchester
across to parts of yorkshire
and northeastern parts of england very
very cold start temperatures sub-zero as
low as minus seven minus eight over
parts of scotland
we'll see the cloud bubbling up through
the day and a few showers appearing
and again these are likely to be wintry
up over the higher ground
into this evening and overnight we're
watching this area of showery activity
coming down through parts of wales the
southwest
again we could see some winter-ness over
the high ground clear to the northeast
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
welcome back to sky news breakfast let's
take a look at the front pages of the
morning's newspapers for you now and as
well as
showing father and son smiling broadly
at each other the telegraph quotes
prince charles's tribute to the duke of
edinburgh
my dear papa was a very special person i
miss him
enormously the express has a similar
headline and says the nation will fall
silent at 3 p.m next saturday
for the duke's funeral the mail on
sunday also carries prince charles's
praise for his father
describing his remarkable and devoted
service to the queen
and the country the sunday times reports
that given coronavirus restrictions the
prime minister will give up his seat at
the funeral
to allow another family member to attend
the mirror highlights what will be a
reunion for princess william and harry
its headline united in grief
with equip the duke might have enjoyed
the people remarks on the vehicle which
will carry the duke's coffin declaring
land rover and out
and given prince philip was the duke of
edinburgh scotland on sunday pictures
the 41 gun salute
held in his honor at the city's famous
castle
in other news the observer reports that
scientists are concerned that regional
coveted 19 hot spots in the uk
such as west yorkshire and the black
country could bring about
a third wave
and reacting to rachel blackmore
becoming the first female jockey ever to
win the grand national
with lots of money backing her the star
asked bookies
why the long face
let's take a look at the weather for you
now with joe
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well
it's a bit chilly this morning but it's
lovely to see some sunshine
and much of the country is there are
still a few showers around and those
that are there
are still on the wintry side
particularly those that are on exposed
northern coasts
now throughout the day we'll find the
cloud bubbling up at times and we will
see some showers developing more widely
some of these still win tree
particularly over parts of the pennines
and certainly early this morning we've
got showers in parts of the greater
manchester area across into parts of
yorkshire
and northeastern england so in terms of
temperatures still not on the high side
six to nine degrees celsius we might
just squeeze a 10 or 11 here or there
but certainly through the latter part of
the day all eyes up towards the
northwest where we see these showers
coming in across parts of northern
ireland
and these going to spread their way down
into parts of wales the midlands
down towards the southeast overnight and
again this could there could be some
winter-ness in these
over the higher ground but we set up
this northeast southwest divide
clear skies to the north and east
another widespread frost for tomorrow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
welcome back with us now to take us
through the newspapers the editor of the
sunday express michael booker and the
broadcaster and diamond welcome back to
both of you
starting with the mail first of all uh
michael you've had a look actually no
we're going to start with the times
uh and this is a story about the triumph
of the outsider
talking about the duke of edinburgh and
actually what a difficult
childhood he had and how difficult it
was made for him when he
he married the queen by the the
courtiers
well i know and this this piece largely
written by
max hastings uh goes into it in a really
interesting way because
over the years just more recently we've
talked about how difficult it is
for any outsider to marry into the royal
family
uh we look at you know from diana to
megan
um and yet um prince philip did it first
um and he did it with such a plum
and here we are paying tribute to a man
who
clearly did it so successfully we've
seen him as the head of the family
um and somebody who steered that family
through some of the most tumultuous
years you can imagine
and yet yes he he was the great great
great grandson of queen victoria
and yet through his own particular royal
circumstances ended up being born
on a kitchen table in corfu
he was almost brought up as an orphan
because his parents separated
his very unhappy prince andrew father
led a very sad life in monte carlo
having been condemned to death in
absentia
by a greek revolutionary court his
mother princess alice
uh was sent to a sanatorium suffering
what they called
was paranoid schizophrenia and he didn't
even get a birthday card from her for 15
years
and he was just pushed around from
pillar to post right throughout his
childhood
his his education being paid for by
various relatives
um and it was only really because he
ended up in the naval college at
dartmouth
and started to make a career for himself
that that's when he mixed in
those particular circles because he was
a royal um and bumped into princess
elizabeth who fell
in love with him um and that spelt out
the rest of his life but
yeah i mean we talk about how difficult
it is for people to enter the royal
family
well he did it first and over these many
many years
73 years of marriage he has he made such
a go of it
and we're paying tribute to the to the
enormous way he did it
now yeah and it was no small task i mean
it was a real struggle there were many
decisions that were taken
over his head one thinks of the the
particular battle
to keep his his family's name and that
was a a
big deal back then in fact max hastings
makes the point he says there were rough
passages
in their relationship as in all
marriages but the queen and the throne
have profited mightily
from the fact that prince philip was
above all else a strong man
princess elizabeth married had she
married a cipher
as some of the courtiers really wanted
such a husband could not have provided
the support
she has needed amidst all the supreme
loneliness
that her pomp and circumstance impose
and while and that's very true and you
can't help thinking today
of whether the supreme loneliness will
land back on her shoulders again
get quite upset thinking about it really
because they were together such a long
time
yeah it is good quite emotional and the
mail making the
the point that the queen also is a a
very strong
woman uh quoting sophie um countess of
wessex
saying that the queen's amazing she
actually spoke to us yesterday our royal
correspondent random mills at uh
windsor but the queen surrounded by a
group of
a very strong woman according to the
male mike yeah that line
uh in that brief exchange between random
mills and uh
sophie could have without charles coming
out yesterday that could have been
leading a lot of newspapers this morning
it's taken a little bit of a backseat
after charles came out but it was a
fascinating insight into
what these women who are around her
think of the queen and the inspiration
they get from the queen because you know
at this time you could see the emotion
uh on the countess of wessex's face
yesterday when she spoke to skye
and how much it's affected her but you
get the impression and reading around
it's the queen that's been the strong
one throughout this she is the strong
one at the moment
she has this it says gang of four women
particularly around her we've got the
contest of wessex we've got lady pamela
hicks
we've got angela kelly her dresser and
we've got princess anne as well and all
of these
strong women all around her giving her
the support she needs
it also reflects the fact that she
recently got two new dogs as well
they've been a comfort
during the last few weeks as she's seen
uh philip uh
uh fades slightly uh and it's
it as as he's um now passed away she has
the the two dogs to keep her company
with the women these dogs mick and
fergus uh they're called
are gonna help give us some of this
support but i think the key thing for
the nation
is that the the uh queen is getting this
great support we also saw
uh prince edward and uh prince andrew go
in to speak to you yesterday charles has
already been in there as
well clearly there's people rallying
around over the next few days we may see
the grandchildren
also go in to see her but she has got
this great support network and it will
be just
fascinating for when the nation next
gets to
glimpser to see how she's doing but
clearly over the last few weeks when we
have seen her doing her engagements and
again
she's had in the back of the mind what's
been happening with philip and the
condition he was in
but she seemed to be as cheerful as ever
and going about her business as ever and
i think
you know once we get the emotional uh uh
powerful funeral out of the way she will
try and be back to business as usual and
how we know it
yes but she will have been hit i mean
this is a a long-term life
partner consort you know the shoulder to
lean on so it will have a tremendous
effect
and more details of the the character of
the duke in the
express uh we know that he was very
modest but he really had no reason to be
such a courageous war hero and
yes that's right and i i think it is
worth reminding everybody of the fact
that he um
he served this country uh and he fought
the enemy
very gallantly and he was mentioned in
dispatches
as they say um in 19 that was in 1941
apparently
he was mentioned in dispatches um after
spotting an unexpected
enemy vessel with his searchlights
and that was all written down as being
particularly courageous and thoughtful
but he really showed his initiative a
bit later on in the war in 1943
when he was only 21 serving on board hms
wallis they were being bombed by
incoming
aircraft and there's no doubt they were
going to be toast
and he had this idea of actually
floating a raft
full of rubbish floating a raft out
setting fire to it so that the incoming
planes would actually be fooled into
thinking
that they'd already bombed the ship
they'd got the ship
and it succeeded and apparently um his
quick thinking because he only had 20
minutes to come up with the idea
before the plane came round again and
had another go at them
that quick thinking saved many lives
that night
um and so everybody who served with him
said you know that was the sort of
initiative
and courage that he had uh as an only
only a 21 year old
fighting for this country in the war and
i just think that's sometimes just worth
reminding people
especially a generation who think of him
as a very old man
indeed you know once upon a time he
wasn't he was younger he was
extraordinarily good-looking young man
and um and he did his bit he really did
fight for this country
yes to have the presence of mind at 21
to to come up with
that decoy simply amazing michael tell
us who
the earl of baldwin was
well again it was one of uh it was one
of the is his jokes uh one of his uh
quick
witticisms that uh he's been uh we got
to know and love
over the years but this is from quite an
early age and it showed
according to the headmaster at
gordenstein uh they just showed you how
uh tired and how he saw through uh
royalty fairly quickly even though he
was a young prince himself
he was a bit of a celebrity at school
and people sometimes came up to him and
asked for his autograph
uh and he found it a bit tiresome
already so sometimes he'd sign uh for
some bemused autograph hunters
uh with the name the earl of baldwin
rather than uh
a prince uh instead so again the
headmaster kurt hahn
uh was uh quoted at the time saying that
he was already tired
of uh of royalty and princeton even at
that time and didn't see it as
something that was particularly attached
to him and he wanted to be his own man
and it showed
won the quick wait and one that he had
his own mind from a fairly early age
another one of his witticisms that uh
that's jumped out with me today as well
as another one from a photographer who
was stood outside balmoral one day
and he came out did the duke in his land
rover and said
look be a good chap and clear off
although i don't think he said quite
clear off but we'll say clear off
for television so 90 minutes later the
duke
drove back the photographer was still
there and he said look it's not the law
around here or anything
but when i tell a chap to clear off he
usually clears off
so clear off so the photographer said he
was so nice about it i cleared off
yes uh betty didn't quite say uh okay
but we know he wasn't very fond of
photographers because he said similar
uh in later life we've got clips of that
uh recorded
um let's uh move away from that story to
back to the express and the
pubs reopening on monday anne
yes they are i know uh but not quite as
you would imagine you
you won't be able to sort of crowd
around a comfy fireside at the moment
which we could all do with it's really
cold today
but i take my hat off to the uh the guys
at the stonehenge pub near stonehenge
um where they create because of course
we can only go to the pub if we sit
outside in the cold
um so they've created their own little
mini stonehenge there in the front yard
so that they have got socially distanced
outdoor seating
uh and it's all very covered safe and i
think it shows true initiative
but i tell you what at the moment you'd
want to take a cushion with you to sit
on
because those look like very very cold
stones to have to sit on to enjoy your
pint
i'm sure a lot of people won't mind
they'd sit down in a blizzard to be
shrinking again uh michael just uh
finally
uh the hairdressers also will be open on
monday will you be have you got an
appointment booked in
not that i'm not saying you need it i'm
not saying you need it i do
i do my hair's getting it's getting a
bit like uh you know one of those tragic
cases of men of a certain age you start
growing their hair again
and to try and regain past glories of
their teenage years so it's gonna look
like that but
i think my barber george in enfield is
already all booked up so it might be a
few weeks just yet
but now this is a story about how if you
grow your hair long enough you may be
able to sell
your lock down locks for a bit of extra
cash because apparently if you get up to
about
12 to 18 inches of good quality usually
blonde hair so
some gentlemen lying alongside their
partners if they're
a bit dorsi this morning you've got the
tv on uh you know might be tempted to
sniff snip some hair off and send it off
to the
wig makers
in demand for this sort of wigs and hair
pieces
uh apparently over the last year so yeah
hundred pound for
for a good uh snip of hair there if
we're not
we're not endorsing what you're
suggesting michael just to be absolutely
clear for the record